your hand your raised hand icon will
only be lowered when you have spoken you
will be invited to speak in order in
which hands are raised please unmute
your microphone when I invite you to
speak and mute it again when you are
finished speaking please note that it
will be live strange to the council's
YouTube channel this morning please be
mindful therefore that members of the
public following the meeting via
livestream will be able to see each of
us on screen please announce yourself by
name when speaking and if you want to
refer to anything in the officers report
can you please first clearly state the
relevant page number and paragraph
number okay are we all here anybody else
coming in source on us all no not at the
moment I let them in if they arrive part
way through okay okay it's the life
opening once livestream started is the
live stream starting is it hold on and
I'll just double check for you
thank you yes it's fine morning
councillors welcome to watch for
District Council's remote licensing and
appeals committee meeting and welcome to
anyone watching this via livestream
agenda item one apologies for absence of
a apologies at all Sonia there were none
in the office can't see mrs. Mason's
hand is raised out so mrs. Mason do you
want to say something
yes thank you Oh councillor Weston
Kelson the Oh quite says his apologies
he's had an unexpected emergency
thank you mrs. Mason thank you
any other apologies agenda item 2 any
substitute members at all none item
number 3 non-members attendee none item
4 to receive declarations of interest
there are none I've been five
concentration on the statement of the
licensing policy to consider the report
of the assistant director of people and
communities outlining changes to the
statement of licensing policy from the
current 2016 2021 policy and requesting
permission to open the consultation with
relevant partners and interested parties
and I believe Steve
I think it screams it Steve Greene's
gonna do the report that's okay thank
you good morning
hopefully everyone can hear me good
morning
the introduction is in relation to the
licensing Act Part 1 section 5 of the
Act the states that each Licensing
Authority must determine its policy with
respect to the exercise of its licensing
function and publish a statement of that
policy before the beginning of that
period as outlined in 3.1 of the
documentation part 1 section 5 3 of the
Act states that before determining these
policy and licensing authority must
consult with a number of interested
parties including the chief officer of
police for the licensing authority area
the fire authority for the area such
persons as the licensing authority
considers to be representative of
holders of premises license issued by
the authority such persons as the
licensing authority considers to be
representative holders of club premises
certificates issued by the authority
such persons as the licensing authority
considers to be representative of
holders of personal licenses issued by
the authority and such other persons as
the licensing Authority considers to be
representative of businesses and
residents in the area
part 1 section 5 6 of the Act states
that where revisions are made the
licensing authority must publish a
statement of the revisions and the
revising licensing statement the policy
has generally remained the same as the
previous publication with the exception
of the creative impact policy the
community of impact policy has been
removed due to the lack of evidence to
support the such policy however this has
been replaced with a new paragraph there
states those applications within the
district for a new premises license or
club premises certificates or variations
they're likely to add
to the existing impact we require the
applicant to did step to demonstrate why
the operation of the premises involved
will not add to the impact already being
experienced the results of the
consultation will be reported to the
licensing appeals committee later this
year prior to the ratification by the
council in December and appendix B is
the timetable for the consultation
period the risks identified relates to
the community of impact policy that this
has been amended due to the lack of
evidence and support of the policy
however paragraph 2.39 reduces the risk
by requesting those applications within
the district to require the applicants
to demonstrate how the operation of
their premises involved will not add to
the already impact that's been
experienced there is no resource
implications associated with the
circulation and the draft statement of
policy and the council's
current statement of licensing policy is
required to be reviewed every five years
in accordance with the licensing act
under a equality impact assessment it
has been completed and they found that
there is no impacts either positive or
negative on protective groups as defined
under the equalities Act of 2010 is
proposed that the committee resolves
that the draft statement of licensing
policy appendix one to be approved for
consultation with the relevant
interested parties and to that the
likely timetable for the consultation
period to be noted and that's the
conclusion of the report Thank You
Steven councillor Mike Wilkinson you
wanted to ask question
thank you Kevin can hear me thank you I
just unmute myself thank you and I just
want to do our Stephen a question if
that for me the paragraph that's been
inserted which is currently in your
report at paragraph three point three
Stephen which it talks about the
applications within the district etc etc
I just wanted to understand make sure I
understand this would I be right in
thinking then that if this were
implemented that future applications
such as the one which is currently being
considered for the red door in railey
that's because there's massive not
massive isn't that loads of conditions
that are being considered with regards
to that application there any
application such as that would have to
show well this is what the impacts on
the local area is at the moment and if
we are to extend their hours into this
at this end the other this is a
potential impact in the future
am i right that I read that correctly
yes I can confirm that they will be
expected to do a full risk assessment of
what impact their business is going to
have on the surrounding areas at the
present time and for the future so yes
okay and one further question chairman
if I may is and so if this is ratified
today we do resolve this today so this
becomes policy will this then affect the
that licensing decision from this day
forward or only those applications are
received from this day forward does that
make sense
this will be implemented from the date
of when the policy is actually
implemented which I believe is in
January to see whether sanyas actually
got there ahead is it January 2021 is
where the implementation and if I can
assist and the purpose of today is that
this will be approved for going out to
public consultation when the public
consultation has actually been completed
it will then come back to this committee
and later in the autumn late October
November time I think we've got a
meeting already scheduled and then you
know any responses that received you in
that consultation period will be
considered by the
committee and after that the policy will
go to full Council for ratification for
adoption in January makes perfect sense
thank you Jim mr. Hoyer you wanted to
ask a question okay chairman um
you say that the there's lack of
evidence to support the policy what if
it's if you what do you mean by that can
you be more depth of that obviously the
the policy is was the Community Impact
policy said if effectively says that
there's a effectively we're saying you
can't develop or you can't add to the
nighttime economy or the or that sort of
economy unless you can absolutely prove
there will not be any fit obviously
these policy is much weaker than that
the new one and I just what you said
there's a lack of evidence to support
the policy as it was I want to know what
what work you've done to check that
evidence and what evidence there was on
top of that you also state there was a
lack of support for that policy can you
say who did not support the policy yes
and just sort of break down a little bit
more around committee of policies so to
provide a little bit of clarity around
it
for a community impact policy to be in
place there must be evidence from Essex
Police to show that there is significant
crime and disorder within the area at
the time prior to the policy being
submitted the previous policy which is
currently in place was when there was a
lot of development taking place within
the town and there was significant
evidence at the time to show that this
policy needs to be supported to restrict
and provide more scrutiny around any
future applications that are that were
being submitted since that time there
hasn't been the evidence provided by
statistical information that the police
have to show that there is eight that
still so can if you can risk and
therefore there is the lack of evidence
statistically to show crime disorder to
carry on with the current measure
however by us implementing this
replacement condition still has a
requirement under our policy to for the
premises or new applicants to
demonstrate what measures they're going
to put in place to try and reduce the
risks does that help and yeah and also
the lack of all up just for
informational I think it's myself and
councillor Hudson who and actually
proposed the policy in the first place
so that's interesting
could you just say was it the police
came to us and said there's no evidence
or did we approach the police asking for
evidence but also about the support
you said lack of support yes it was
myself the approached Essex Police
asking for information statistical
information to determine whether to
continue into the community impact
policy or whether there was insufficient
evidence
they said unfortunately there was
insufficient evidence from the licensing
team of Essex Police that could provide
support for continuing with the current
measures so I basically said the police
did not support the policy is what
you're saying when you say lack of
support the case yes under statistical
information yes right the police okay
yes and one music or not thank you yes
yeah that was all there was something
else um head back on it's gone from my
head at the moment so I'll leave that
one think that you guys come back
counselor mrs. Mason please you want a
question thank you yeah I would like to
address this to the officer under three
point one I think he's picked this up
when he was reading it out hesitation
there's a duplication there in bullet
point three or five can you just confirm
that is a duplication and it shouldn't
be another person or group of people
that win that meant to be yes I think
you rightly pointed out there is
actually a duplication in the report and
it shoots just be those their personal
license holders those that are holding a
premises my
since those that are holding a club
premises certificate and any other
persons as the licensing authority
considers to be representative of
businesses and local residents right so
that the duplication of the premises
license issued by that authority is
pretty a duplication and shouldn't read
otherwise thank you for that
clarification on the same point it says
that we rely singeth RT must consult
with such other persons as the licensing
authority considers to be representative
of businesses and residents in that area
can you give an indication of how you
determine which businesses and residents
you go out to and which groups are
included for example do you include
parish councils yes I can confirm that
this is a full consultation so we'll go
out to residents businesses and we'll go
via the parish councils as well tours he
try and spread the request for as many
responses as we can across the district
yeah thank you just start with some
clarification look well your same
residence how are you going out to
residents I mean oppositely are you
going to write to every address what
means of communication are you using
because we've got thousand residents oh
I doubt that you're writing to each
other know what we'll be using is we'll
be using our communications team to
announce press releases and also as well
we'll be using social media and if there
is anyone else here that has hasn't got
access to those or facilities then I'll
see where we've been using community
groups as well to try and make sure that
we have a wide range of responses across
the district this is just a verification
on reading the record I find that
certain paragraphs are bolded it's that
are they called it because there's some
alteration there are they bold to
emphasis to that paragraph
and if so how do you determine that
emphasis please yes there is
key PAGASA have been bolded out in the
document we have done that for a
specific reason to actually draw the
attention to anyone that is looking at
submitting an application to focus on
those key points but they are actually
then broken down in more detail within
the documents so this is Regis to
highlight the key points that they need
to certainly show evidence when
submitting their application counsel mr.
Masson counselor mr. Hoyer you want to
come back yes thank you it was actually
it was around the consultation so I want
to reassess the questions that Cassie's
Mason has asked however it's um you've
sort of touched on it are we are you do
will you use or direct people from the
use of it social media for the
consultation and how will you measure
the response to the consultation what's
an acceptable response anything we get
back or does you have to meet a certain
standard we'll be using all types of
media as you've mentioned and through
our communications scene we will see
collate the information and then we will
then obviously present that the reports
back to you with the findings we will
have a look to see whether there is
repetition of certain sort of comments
that obviously we can then sort of
summarize to say we have had so many
with the same responses but we will also
provide you with the full sort of report
if you wish to see the full breakdown of
all the responses we will certainly give
you a summary so you don't have to to
sort of scrutinize too much over the
information yourself
Thank You countess are there any more
questions at all councilors okay at the
end of the report that on page five
point two there are two recommendations
I move I move that we accept the
recommendations the first one is a draft
statement of licensing policy appendix a
be approved for consultation with all
relevant interested parties I'm going to
do the first one first if you vote on
the first recommendation if you're happy
to do that members I will ask Sonia to
call out names and indicate if you're
happy to do the first recommendation
that's okay Sonia if I may and just for
clarity I'll second that set pose also
it's a lease it's recorded Thank You
counsel Wilkinson Sonia funny your mics
on lots of
counselor counselor Betty and would you
like a recorded vote and also would you
like to vote for against or abstain no
recorded vote for Thank You counselor
mrs. Gooding would you I could vote or
do you like to vote for against or
abstain no recorded vote and for thank
you thank you
so counselor hoy would you like a
recorded vote or do you like to vote for
what forgetting to abstain against the
recorded vote for the motion Thank You
councillor Lucas Gil would you like a
recorded vote would you like to vote for
against or abstain Thank You counselor
mrs. Macpherson would you like a
recorded vote and would you like to vote
for against draw abstain no recorded
vote and for thank you
counselor mrs. Mason would you like it
recorded goat and would you like to vote
for against or abstain Thank You
councillor Merrick would you like a
recorded version would you like to vote
for against or abstain Thank You
councillor mrs. Shaw would you like to
recorded vote and would you like to vote
for against drops game no recorded vote
on follow motion Thank You councillor
Shaw would you like a recorded vote and
would you like to war against drugs
stain no recorded vote all the emotion
and slowness is Western would you like a
recorded vote would you like to the poor
against to abstain Thank You councillor
Wilkinson recorded vote for against to
abstain no recorded vote and for the
motion thank you Thank You councillor
Williams would you like to a recorded
vote for against or abstain go and stand
for please thank you that's the likely
timetable for the consultation period be
noted appendix B I move that second on
that please yes I can do that Thank You
Sonia would you like to do the prelims
again please of course
so councillor FG recorded vote for
against to abstain going against and for
Thank You councillor missus Gooding
recorded vote for against to abstain no
recorded vote and for Thank You
councillor hoy recorded vote for against
towards thing thanks for calling folks
for the question Thank You councillor
Lucas kill recorded vote for against to
abstain thank you
Lancel mrs. Macpherson recorded vote for
against or abstain cancel missing I'll
do my neck sir
novelty boat and Thor thank you mrs.
Mason recorded vote for against to
abstain yes ma'am and for the motion
thank you
can't see Merrick recorded vote for
against or abstain thank you plan sir
mrs. Shaw recorded vote for against or
abstain no recorded vote for the motion
counselor sure recorded vote for against
abstain no recorded vote for the motion
Thank You counselors is Western recorded
vote for against to abstain no recorded
vote and for the motion thank you cancer
Wilkinson recorded vote for against
retain no and for thank you and
counselor Williams recorded vote for
against George stunning no and for the
motion thank you thank you
fully carried members thank you very
much
agenda item 6a proposal for an increase
to the hackney carriage tariff by
reducing the yardage the yardage mr.
greener the council's license officer
will present the report again thank you
okay this is a proposal from the
licensing trade from the hackney
carriage taxi trait to increase the
current hackney carriage Terry fair it's
been in place since April 2017 the
proposal for reviewing the fit is to set
out in section and 66 and 65 of the
local government miscellaneous
provisions acts 1976 following the
requirements of the eight the council's
licensing team undertook formal
consultation with
and the public on the proposals for the
increase we have a summary of responses
set out in power grouse 3.72 3.12 below
the final stage of the formal process
required by the act is to bring the
matter to the licensing and appeals
committee for a decision it is the
matter for the committee to make the
decision to increase the fares as per
the trades proposals set out in this
report or alternatively to not make any
increase at this time a copy of the
process flowchart for reviewing fare
increases in accordance with the Act can
be found at Appendix A the decision
being recommended is that the trade has
proposed the increase to the authorized
fare terrace for Hackney carriages as
outlined in Appendix B of this report it
is a matter for the committee to accept
or reject the proposal taken into
account to the contents of this report
if the committee's mind is to approve
the proposed increase the committee is
further asked to agree that the decision
on which dates the increased fares are
to be implemented be delegated to the
assistant director of peoples and
communities in consultation with the
portfolio holder for licensing provided
that the implementation date shall be no
later than the end of February 2021 the
reason for the increased proposed by the
trade on the 9th of January 2020 the
trade requested an increase to the
authorized fare terrace this has been
requested is set out in Appendix C in
the report in summary the trades
contention was that although inflation
has remained reasonably low in the UK
over the last three years prices of
goods and services have still gone up
since the last fare increase in 2017 the
trade states that using an inflation
calculator every 1 pound spent in 2016
to 2017 now cost an average
one pound and nine point zero nine eight
based on the average inflation increase
of 3.2 percent per year trade further
urges the pensions increase alike are
linked to inflation and there is
evidence of weight wage growth over the
last few years the trade maintained that
an increase would also be in line with
other transportation industries such as
rail fares increases which are linked to
inflation the trade did not produce any
evidence or statistical data to support
the replication so it is not clear what
inflation measures they have used
however the Office of National
Statistics data on CPI at levels since
2017 showing that CPI has constantly
been below 3% for this period if the
committee our mind is to accept the
trade proposal increase the fares would
be affected and set out in the table
that's listed under 3.2 in accordance
with the Act on 14th of February 20 2011
Singh team sent out an email to all
hackney carriage drivers outlining the
proposal for the fare increase an online
survey was created to record the details
of the survey paper copies of the
questions were sent to the drivers that
we did not hold a valid email address
the consultation for the online entries
was concluded on the 1st of February
2020 and the postal entries concluded on
the 16th of February 2020 to allow
sufficient time for responses the copy
of the letter sent out to the drivers
sharing the question is attached as
appendix D the survey was sent out to
all hadn't encouraged licensed drivers
247 of them and 56% of the drivers
responded which was 139 drivers the
results showed that eighty four point
nine percent of the drivers supported
the increase and 15.1% drivers did not
feel that they could support it based on
the result
and in accordance with the act that
matter was then taken to the next stage
which was the public consultation the
public consultation started on the 10th
of March 2020 with a press release from
the council and a web banner was placed
on the council's website consultation
was open to members of the public using
an online forum to collate the responses
it was proposed to allow members of the
public to submit their comments in
person however the current restrictions
prevented us from offering this service
the signage was placed on the high
streets and widely advertised on social
media a copy of the questions were posed
to the public can be a found in Appendix
A the consultation period conclusion on
the 20th of April 2020 at minimum the 30
days as required by the Act during the
consultation period the council received
60 968 responses from members of the
public a copy of the responses is
attached as Appendix F and redacted as
necessary to comply with the
requirements of the data protection act
2018 in summary the majorities of those
that responded were over the age of 60
and over 47.1% and most were in
full-time employment
forty two point six percent followed
closely by those that were retired 41.2%
the survey found thirty eight point two
percent of those that had responded
supported the fare increase and sixty
one point eight percent did not support
the change the majority of the comments
for not supporting the fare increase
were relating to the perception that
taxes were already expensive and a few
examples of the comments were listed
under three point one three we did
approach the trait for a statement from
the recognized trade association under
four point one there was no formal
comments from the recognized trade
association known as the voice of reason
the only request that which was made is
that the committee's supports the
increase and implementation of the
increase should be delayed because of
the current code mid-nineteen panel
situation
and there is a recommendation that the
decision on which date the increase
fares to believe Clemente it to be done
delegated to the assistant director of
peoples and communities in consultation
with the portfolio holder for licensing
provided the implementation date is no
later than the end of February 2021 in
addition to the representations made by
the trades and the outcome of the two
consultations the following information
is available to the committee to assist
you in making your decision making 5.2
shows a comparison with other licensed
overit licensing authorities within
Essex the magazine the private higher
taxing magazine publishes a nationwide
fair comparison chart and that can be
shown seen as a appendix G below is the
extract from the chart showing the
comparisons across Greater Essex
Colchester is currently at the highest
point at 6 pounds 80 for every 2 mile
fair and ruptured currently sits at 6
pound 20 with the proposed increase at 6
pound at 40 as of April 2009 T the
current national average is 5 pounds 98
with Rochford was the seventh most
expensive authority within Essex the
proposed increase would make the fair
for two miles six pound forty this would
be the same that of that of Harlow and
Southend Borough Council that have also
had a fair tariff increase recently by
present Colchester is the highest that's
6 pounds 80 for the tube fair and Epping
Forest being the lowest at five pounds
50 to assist year I've included as well
from the Office of National Statistics
the petrol prices the contestant
contestant made by the trade that the
cost of feel has increased since the
date of the last fare increase is not
fully borne out of the evidence although
fair price it costs did
increase during the period since 2017
lay on and now lower than the 2017 in
the first quarter of 2017 the date of
the last fare increase the average cost
of unleaded filled was 1 p.m. 19 per
litre since that time the cost of an or
feel increased reaching a high of one
pound 28 in quarter free of 2018 before
decreasing to a low of one pound and 9 P
in quarter 2 of 2020 and the chart is
within 5 point 5 which shows the
breakdown of the cost of fuel and the
full report can be found on the Office
of National Statistics website there are
six companies that provides this
information for all companies and to
supermarkets that take part in the
weekly fuel price surveys providing the
you LS P which is the unleaded petrol
and diesel and super unleaded fuel
prices and it covers around 65 percent
of the market the CPI also known as
Consumer Price Index again which is
sourced from the Office of National
Statistics the chart is shown at five
point six the chart shows a steady
decrease of the CPH I measures of the
consumer price inflation falling a peak
in August 2017 and the CPH I remaining
below three percent over this period
this means that the average prices have
increased since 2017 but at a rate less
than three percent per annum again the
latest report can be found under the
compute a consumer price inflation UK
March 20 20 out lines the price indexes
in 5.9 the reports directly states the
relation to transport over the last two
years the contribution from Transport
has shown more variation than any other
group ranging from no
point seven-five in August 2018 to no
point not 17 September twin 2019 much of
the movement comes from the changes to
the price of motor fuel low
contributions from air fares secondhand
cars have also changed over this period
the contribution from Transport was
naught 0.16 percent points in March 2020
well within this total motor fields have
made downwards cross abusing of naught
point naught 6% points average petrol
price stood at one pound nineteen point
four pence per litre in March 2020 the
lace observed since February 2019 while
the average diesel price where one pound
twenty three point eight prior pence per
litre the lowest since March 2018
the data shows that while there has been
increases over the period since the last
fare increase were implemented the
council cannot substantiate the trade
claim of an average three point two
percent increase over the relevant
period and the full table can be found
on the Office of National Statistics
website under alternative options
considered the council has followed the
necessary legal procedure under the Act
to enable the committee's to increase
the fares as proposed by the trade it
remains open to the committee to decline
to do so at this time some additional
testings of metres will be required
under the resource implications by the
licensing team on the date of
implementation of the proposed fare
increases to ensure they are calibrated
correctly this can be completed within
our existing resources under the limp
legal implement implications the power
to fix fares is given under Section 65
of the local government miscellaneous
provisions Act 1976 any representations
received must be considered by the
committee equality and diversity
implications
the public sector equality applies to
the policy applies to the council when
it makes decisions a equality impact
assessment has been completed and found
to be no impacts either positive or
negative on protective groups as defined
under the Equality Act 2010 the
recommendation is to propose that the
committee resolves that the application
by the trade determines for the fare
increases as outlined in Appendix B 2
this report taking into account the
representations received and the
contents of this report if the committee
is minded to approve the proposed
increase that the it is to be agreed
that the implementation date of the
increased fares be delegated to the
assistant director of peoples and
communities in consultation with the
portfolio holder of licensing and this
to be no later than the end of February
2021 and that is the end of the report
see them soon you want to come in on a
question thank you Kevin it's not a
question there's a couple of points I'd
like to make if I may and the first
thing I'm going to say is that I think
it goes without saying that we all
recognize at these difficult times and
need for people to earn money the taxi
business is no different from that and I
I sympathize with them however I having
read to report that Stephens has gone
through ready beforehand I've got some
real problems with this I'm afraid I'd
like to draw members attention to the
table that is in paragraph 3.1 and it
starts saying that the committee was
minded to accept the trade proposed fare
increase fares will be affected as set
out in the table below now I've worked
out that it started the it ranges from a
three point to two percent increase for
two miles which is what they are cited
they started within the reports up to an
8 percent increase for four miles and
most of them being around about the
seven and a half percent increase that's
a massive increase
to try and impose on people and for
example if we look at for miles the the
trade is proposing ATP ATP increases so
actually if it's if we were to look at
3% which is average at the moment it
should only be 30 P and the longest
distance 20 miles were the fit the trade
133 pounds 60 increase it should only be
one pound 40 and again which was spoken
about by Steven about the the the the
fuel if I take chairman if I could take
members to Appendix C Appendix C appears
to be an email to Steven from somebody
because it's service its redacted and
that the whole evidence of this email is
based upon fuel price assumptions and it
starts out by saying in 2016 the average
fuel price of diesel or the other price
of diesel rather was one pound 11 up to
20 it's one pound 31 so all their
calculations are based on that and and
in actual fact as steam is rightly said
it's not that anymore I filled my cart
yesterday and one pound 11 and and and I
think sadly for the trade their
application has come at the wrong time I
know that they couldn't help cove at 19
but and fuel prices have gone right down
and I think that with but bearing that
in mind bearing in mind the additional
financial hardship to everybody not just
the taxi industry but everybody I think
this is an unreasonable request at this
time because I think it's too high you
know asking for fare increases ranging
up to 8% is it's way beyond any
inflation process and I and I find it
very strange that they were asking for
that so chairman I'm going to be voting
against this at this motion
thanks for looking soon counselor mrs.
Mason thank you madam chairman before I
speak to the report in general I'd like
the officer who has given us a very
comprehensive and complex report on
which is a very difficult subject I'd
like to ask him for two questions to
clarify one of the men
public's responses there's a claim that
the minimum fare was the highest well
I've been unable to check that it's
probably hidden in the stats but I I'm
not sure if that's an accurate a
cetacean or not but it's not me
taking the averages in the two-month
fairs which you've shown up on 3.2 the
mean average would be 6 pounds what so
not 3.2 it's on a different show didn't
mean that it could be 6 foot 2 in the
average between the highest and the
lives would be 6 pounds 15 so we are
slightly out to kill killed two there so
there's just the one one question on the
minimum fair a relationship with that
with other districts and the second
question is one which I'm quite
concerned about when the survey went out
we survey asked the reasons not to
support the fare increase and there was
a questionnaire which said yes no but if
you answered none you had to give your
reasons however if someone answered yes
they should have been given the equal
opportunity to give their reasons we
should be given equal weight to
residents who are opposed to potential
fare increase as to those that are in
favor and I was concerned that that
balance wasn't there hopefully that will
be done in future but it wouldn't
suggest before I carry on could he just
give me some information about that
minimum fare statement
yes
yes I can and I haven't got the starting
fares for each of the districts however
like saying there is all licensing
authorities have to provide the private
higher in taxi magazine waive for what
their to meet to
there is so that they can have a a ver
ajikko whole of the UK which obviously
I've highlighted on five points too in
relation to Rock Chad's been the highest
fare in the area I have included in that
report the the fare for southend-on-sea
which is six pound for tea at the two
miles and then we have ourselves at the
moment at six pound 20 with the proposal
for six pound for tea and castle point
is at six pounds Brazelton is at six
pounds and finally Farouk if we're
counting down across the Thames corridor
is also at six pounds as well so while
Heron has you got the actual starting
fare but this is certainly what we use
in previous consultations and he's sort
of used nationally as a good sort of
wager to compare us with other other
authorities is that sufficient or would
you try and get some more information I
think I think the complexity of the
subject and the wealth of new
information that we've had and I must
admit I've spent time reading and
rereading it but that's more than
adequate thank you for that madam
chairman I I'm concerned here similar to
councillor Wilkinson that the average
fare is already above the average for
the locality that's my first concern my
second concern here is that the claim
fulfil cost made by the trade does not
seem to be substantiated by any of the
information that we had seen in front of
us today and seems to be overstated at
best the the consultation period is
significant we only had 68 responses and
I'm going to hold my hands up here I was
probably notified at this consultation
he didn't register
and it passed me by the period was in
lockdown it's no reflection on officers
it's an unfortunate situation that's
occurred but having said that I don't
think that's a representative response
at which is something that's happened to
lockdown so there is a move that
possible deferment or re consultation if
the proposal was reworked might be
acceptable most importantly the trade
inflation figure that they provided was
not substantiated by officers not
substantiated by themselves and as
stated in the report there was no
empirical evidence or data provided I'm
concerned that this application is not
backed up by adequate information and I
will move for refusal if I have a
seconder for that but you say okay count
all your second in there okay Thank You
Sonia where do I go from here do I still
got three more people and Sue them some
cancer mrs. Weston I think because
counselor who is seconded it if you
could go to counsel please thank you um
yes but obviously we're now talking to
the the motion for deferral I think um
refusal if you do counselor hi I'm
caster mrs. Mason moved for deferral
also known as she moved for refusal but
I can't get very confused absurd I heard
the word refusal cuz I refused I thought
to start with and didn't get a second
though I'm happy to move the motion to
refuse if counts the HOS not yeah hi
well I'm just trying to do this properly
because he's quite important I thought
counselor Wilkins that loop refused
really but hadn't been seconded no no I
hadn't moved a motion cancel hide just
indicated my pension so III just
indicated my intentions missus counsel
mrs. Mason I believe that's for either
way I just misheard both of you the you
know the refusal it needs to be honest
they're quite similar in many ways
because we're not this wouldn't be
implemented into much later anyway I
have concerns around the pricing I'd
also worked out the same sensors
councillor Wilkinson it does seem quite
a lot but also had concerns around the
spoilage these things someone explain
what the Sportage is hundred pound
charge it's being reintroduced is this
if there is damage to the taxi answer to
that one as well and I think the the
consultation in itself would would be
flawed and by no fault of the officers
because at the point of time it took
place but obviously fuel prices were
falling anyway prior to the to the
pandemic taking hold and obviously have
dropped since although they had seemed
to know stabilized and I think some of
the data on this which whatever the data
is because it's not being supplied is
dubious well then we just have danced
for about Sportage I'll be grateful
thank you Steven before we go on to
Steven can I've got two more the members
can I have take them first and perhaps
you can answer the questions at the same
time I council F D please Thank You
councillor Weston three points one is
that 50% of taxi drivers 56% of taxi
drivers actually responded to them
actually having a pay rise and 15% of
them said they basically didn't want to
play rice so I really only 41% of the
taxi drivers actually said though that
she liked to play by so that it's not
even over half half of them have
actually said that she want to go charge
more money the second one is it's look
people okay some people enjoy penny
taxies but people use taxes because they
have to use taxis and I feel that public
transport is
especially going to be cut especially
out we're in right and the countryside
where I am in other places because
people just lack of use of it at the
moment and also with the fuel the fuel
we can't really have an opinion on the
fuel because the price of fuel goes up
and down all the time it's this market
happens with the market but we can say
we feel it's cheaper to do longer
journeys and he used to do lots of small
stops so really with the percentage I
think the percentage should not go up
with the longer journeys we even
actually go down because it's actually
saving money when they're doing longer
journeys Vaness and i cannot support
this for those reasons that's me thank
you
I can't you can't account so missus sure
please
Thank You Carol yeah and the figures
don't add up what has been given on this
report refusal on this and perhaps we
could get a better up-to-date we call
when it comes if it comes through again
this isn't against Stephen appreciate
because it's a he sector what the
figures he's got but because it's Co V
everything something I don't think we
should be an alone I mean our taxis to
put up the prices just because they want
so and they're not actually justified
why that's my opinion Thank You
councillor Steven can you answer two
counts of mr. hallease question please
thank you yes this in relation to the
spoilage it relates to sauna is sick or
ill inside a vehicle obviously the
driver then has to go away to get the
vehicle cleaned but always he could take
them out of work special sort of a
Friday or Saturday night so we
previously had a Sportage in there not
in the current fare increase because it
the current fare table it says at the
discretion of the driver the the actual
trades wanting to an actual fixed amount
in there rather than leaving it open to
interpretation does that help
yes thank you how does that compare to
other authorities I don't have that
information it's not something that is
openly sort of publicized but it's quite
common across the trace to have a fixed
amount it was previously at 75 / 75
pounds on our previous fare table before
we change it to the discretion so
hundred pounds would be in average about
the same as what you would expect thank
you please last question Thank You
chairman and it's probably more of a
question to officers and I agree for a
lot of the comments and I wondered if
this could not be deferred and for a
period of time for a further review post
you know this or a situation wherein is
no one they'll be discussing the motion
on the table and well if an officer can
ask if it ants me please okay accounts
cat counts cancer mrs. Macpherson we we
are debating a motion for refusal we
have to deal with that first thank you
very much thank you Sonia okay members
there is a motional table to refuse this
item so if you'd like to do the prelims
please we can see mrs. Mason is
indicating does she want to speak sorry
counsel mrs. Mason did you want it's
customary to be announced to come back
at the end as first motor to come back
safe if you'll just bear with me I am
moving for refusal I do realize that
there are concerns with the taxi trade
and we we are all aware of them however
it is up to the trade to provide a
justification for an increase and in my
view that hasn't been done which is why
the motion is for refusal should they
it's at some further time provide
information I don't think it's up to our
officers to provide information for the
trade
saundh the information that's given to
them is by understanding see which is
why I didn't vote could you throw but
the refusal so just that's just a point
of clarification but the motion is
refusal Thank You mr. Mason okay members
so we've got a motion on table by at
Council miss Mason seconded by
Councillor mr. hoy Sonia if you'd like
soon thank you okay so cancel oft would
you like a recorded vote or do you want
to vote for against abstain for the
motion to refuse no recorded vote and
for the motion to refuse counselor mrs.
Gooding recorded vote for against drug
staying
no recorded vote and for the motion
Thank You councillor hoy recorded vote
for against to abstain the guys recorded
vote for the motion okay cancer Lucas
kill who did vote for against or abstain
Thank You counselor mrs. Macpherson
recorded vote for against or abstain
against a recorded vote and for the
motion thank you
Thank You council mrs. Mason recorded
vote for against to abstain thank you
madam chairman against an early call
each vote there's no need and for the
motion of whistling thank you
Hanson AmeriCorps did vote for against
abstain no recorded vote or the motion
panther mrs. Shaw the corner or against
or abstain sorry no record about four
motion Thank You Chancellor sure no
recorded vote for the motion yeah
counselor mrs. Weston are we called no
recorded vote and I'm staying in please
Kancil wilkinson no recorded votes and
for the motion Thank You councillor
Williams no recorded votes and for the
refusal thank you
okay members of eleven for the motion
and one of things they should thank you
for that next one is so item seven is
the flexibility to private hiking
vehicle conditions due to the coab in
nineteen and even you're gonna do this
one again please thank you there's
something about this is reports for the
committee to determine whether to allow
an extension of one year for those
vehicles listed in paragraph four point
one of this report my advisee in pn c--
sorry council lucas go could you please
state your reason as to why you think
this should be in private and
confidential there's nothing in here the
information it's provided is all generic
so this well there is this is not this
is not a private and confidential that
it's not an exempt item all of the
information in it is publicly available
so there is no reason for us to go into
exempt into it you know and to exclude
the press and public indeed Thank You
counselor my carry on this thank you
thanks Steven that's okay on the 21st of
May twenty twenty day week Milligan the
company director have access anyone
requested some flexibility to
the current conditions in relation to
the vehicle requirements agreed by the
appeals committee access anyone runs a
school contract with South in Borough
Council currently the operations
management of the contract is being
transferred to a newly formed
partnership between Southend Borough
Council and an independent company
called London Fire the joint partnership
is called vector tow the transition
coupled with covin 19 situation has made
the plans move moving forward more
problematic and as a result 7 Borough
Council has approached access anyone to
extend their current contract for a
further year until July 2021
this contract we serve in Borough
Council exceeds 30,000 the fleet of
licensed private hire vehicles by excess
anyone is now aging with free of the
vehicles reaching the vehicles age
requiring the vehicle replacement by the
licensing team before the next renewal
to allow access anyone to meet the
demands of the contract they have
requested an extension of 1 year for
those vehicles that should be replaced
due to the shortness of the extension
and the clarity as to the Victoria's
plans to moving forward is not viable to
invest in replacing rolling stock at
this Junction should a more expensive
contract be offered they would be at
this point to making the necessary
investment to replace the vehicles
hackney carriage and private hire driver
vehicle and operator's license
conditions 103.1
8 of the hanging carriage condition
states the vehicle must be no more than
6 years old when first licensed and will
not be relicensed
if more than 12 years old from the datas
registration 4.1 outlines the details of
the fleet of the vehicles and by access
anyone and the free highlighted vehicles
are the vehicles it relates this report
relates to the alternative options
available to the members which to refuse
the extension for the vehicles a
as any anyone would have to consider
whether they can meet the requirements
of the contract with fewer vehicles risk
implications the only risk identified
relates to the age of the vehicles it
needs to be acknowledged that ageing
vehicles are more prone to breakdowns
however in order to minimize the risk
access anyone has confirmed they carry
out preventative maintenance checks on
these vehicles at ten weekly intervals
in addition to MIT is being carried out
on the vehicles at six monthly intervals
a copy of the maintenance check report
is attached there is no resource
implement eight implications in respect
of this decision there is no legal
implications to this isolated request
this request is being considered to due
to extreme circumstances and is
considered on its own merit and will not
impact on any other licensed driver or
vehicle excuse me like this coming
Arthur Williams was just wrong me he's
not to leave the meeting Thank You cats
for sure in relation to equality and
diversity implications this decision
relates to the transportation of
children to and from school with
disabilities the decision of the
committee will impact on the number of
vehicles available to the school for the
safe passage of their students by
reducing the number of vehicles within
the axis anyone fleets
the number of students able to access
school would be decreased or for them to
find alternative means of transport to
the school the recommendation is to
propose that the committee resolves to
grant the request by access anyone to
license the vehicles for an extension
for a one year beyond the requirements
outlines within condition 103 point one
eight and that's into the reports Thank
You Stephen councilor I'm still looking
someplace Thank You Sherman and right
got a question which has arisen I got a
question for Stephen actually chairman
if that's okay which was risen from my
concern over reading this report I think
it doesn't take I think I think we all
understand the the pressures that
perhaps this kept this company is put
under and their reasons for m-44 try and
what they're trying here but my concern
is that the there are guidelines and
rules that are in place with regard to
the age of vehicles for a reason those
those reasons primarily around safety
safety the passenger's maintenance etc
we're not just talking about
transportation of anybody here we're
talking about the transportation of
vulnerable children and vulnerable
members of society and and so what these
actually they're actually asking us to
do is to authorize them to continue
using vehicles that are older than the
guidelines would ordinarily permit them
to do to carry vulnerable people which
is where I have a problem with this and
and it appears to be born when you read
further into the reports and they talk
about their contract and if they get
more more of a contract to start
investing they certainly other it
appears to be born out of a financial
concern understandably I might add as
opposed to one of safety and with a huge
respect to this particular company I'm
more interested in the safety their
passengers the name of their financial
situation so I'm I've got a real concern
about this and perhaps chairman I could
just ask Stephen green a question about
this because if we if we as members
agree to this extension and god forbid
there was an incident that were to
happen with one of those vehicles which
caused injury stress or otherwise what
implication would that have to rupture
District Council what what would we
opening ourselves up to the fact that we
have authorized them to use these
vehicles that are beyond the age we
would normally have done purely as a
financial reason for that company I
think we might be opening ourselves up
to a bit of criticism there and I just
wonder if you might know the answer to
that it is a difficult question to be
honest as to what implications it could
have on the council and yes that
obviously resets that the age of the
vehicles
reason which as you pointed out that we
have to make sure that the
transportation of the public is our
paramount priority and to make sure that
we do safeguard to those in relation to
the age of vehicles there has been a lot
of questions in the past around age of
vehicles and whether a vehicle that is
aged eleven years and six months is any
safer than a vehicle that is twelve
years and three months so there is those
or there has been legal challenges but
we felt that an age of twelve is a
suitable vehicle and a suitable age for
a private higher vehicle so we also
include within that twelve years is also
the limousines the chauffeur vehicles
it's not just sort of school contract
vehicles in relation to this decision I
believe that you would be able to imply
any sort of other sort of conditions or
rules that you would like them to also
comply with to make sure that ozzie we
ensure the paramount safety of the
public as they have included they do
have additional checks above and beyond
what we expect of any other private
higher vehicle by conducting the ten
weekly checks and that is done by a
external partner and as external company
if something went wrong in relation to
injury to the public yes then there will
be scrutiny around the decision making
from even the Health and Safety
Executive or OSI more to also the
company as to what measures they had put
in place to safeguard to the public the
decision words be considered but I think
the onus is more upon the company
themselves rather than the merace
District Council but I think that there
certainly will be a question they're
being asked of the council as to why we
it was approved chairman would you mind
if I just come back with one thank you
and thank you for asking
answer that Steven I think I said it's
very helpful my my observation from
reading it is that this is that they are
basically saying if you don't approve
this
then some children going to go without
without transport which i think is
really unfair what they're doing is
they're turning the onus they're putting
on us the guide like you know they set
themselves up as a business to do what
they're doing and for whatever reason
they now can't afford to do it so what
they're doing is they want us to break
to bend the rules for them and if we
don't then children are going to suffer
and that's the way I read it and at this
moment in time I'm not in favor of it
thank you very much
Thank You council Wilson yeah it's for
mr. hoi Thank You chairman um I agree
councillor Wilson Wilkinson on this
surah Nene what your name rule and to me
it just says they've got themselves in a
commercial hull by agreeing a one-year
extension realized three of their
vehicles won't qualify because their age
and are now hunting around for ways to
get around it I could see no reason why
they couldn't do a year's lease on a
vehicle they're quite common and that
would fill the hole I'm very
uncomfortable with releasing
reenacting our standards and I was very
concerned with the statement made by
Stephen green know that it wouldn't
affect any remember you're quite word
you've got your wording but any other
license cab
I think it's effectively what you're
saying and and I don't see why we make
it a policy just for one company
I assume you're saying it wasn't benefit
anyone else because that no one else has
vehicles of that an age which would be
affected by it so that's the first
question the second question is around
the what we're actually agreeing if it
was agreed which I can't agree is it
beyond the one year so we going to agree
an extension of one year beyond the
requirements outlined within condition
103.1 eight that is mentioned in
paragraph I avoid it now three those
three point and this is the issue so
three point one says about condition and
three point two is the condition so the
condition is the vehicle must not be
more than six years old when first
licensed it will not be realized as if
more than 12 years old from the date of
registration so although the report is
worded as though we just changed the
last bit of that we're actually changing
the first bit as well so bike
by agreeing a one-year extension to
103.1 eight we're also saying that
vehicles mate must not be more than
seven years old now and I don't think
that's the intention of this report
because that then would affect that
would affect other licensed cabs there's
people with us six a vehicle between six
or seven years who could now license the
cab which I'm sure wasn't the intention
from new so they're my two questions
need answering and I turned at this
moment I can't support the
recommendation thank you yes in relation
to and the comment that I added in there
in relation to legal implications it was
because the work that is provided by
access anyone is very very bespoke the
vehicles that have been listed in 4.1
are wheelchair accessible vehicles they
are not the standard sort of cars and
they are very large agency written
master vehicles and two transports and
wheelchair users and people with
mobility issues they have got tailgate
ramps which you don't find on normal
sort of private hire vehicles and also
lot of the other sort of school contract
vehicles like so they are very bespoke
and that's why in the report I actually
put in there that this wouldn't actually
have any impact on any other licensed
vehicles or drivers because of the
structure of their business and the
nature of their business in relation to
the condition outlined on 3.2 the
proposal is not to change anything in
relation to the six years old aspect is
purely that they're asking to extend on
those three vehicles to take it from 12
years up to 13 years is that the
proposal or the request by the company
yeah if I come back on that the well one
is the recommendation as it's written
that would also extend it extend the six
year one as well well he asked quite
clear
for everyone to read he doesn't specify
the 12-year well its specialized
deconditioning 103.1 a weenie
if you're just saying that the
Whittington one year even the
requirements outlined is clearly both
its changing so I can't support you on
that that basis at this point I'd like
to move refusal on the base on the place
off I've raised I don't know anyone once
the second deck to have second that's
okay thank you so because a motion to be
a few second oh by accounts and my real
concern
we just caveat counselor mrs. Shaw do
you have a question at all yes I do I
was really doing reading the report on
all of us have and the inspection report
really highlighted some problems and
it's been noted that we are taking
children on these there's the efficiency
of the brake service ninety sixty eight
percent and what else was there the the
handbrake needed to be repaired so these
vehicles I'm sure I'll set my vehicle in
I'm going to drive it for an MOT because
things were wrong but we're asking
they're asking us to approve vehicles
that aren't really Road worthy and it's
gonna be as other members have said
dangerous right it could potentially be
dangerous right for the children to
travel in Council miss Hawtree sorry
counselor mrs. Mason please thank you
madam chairman I think we're all
concerned over this for more than one
reason we're concerned because company
is put in a difficult situation and
we've concerned over the fact that we
eventually we effectively been in the
situation where we either approve this
so that the children can go to school in
a vehicle that would not normally be
satisfactory to our standards of albeit
and we'll recognize that the firm has
gone owner above to try and mitigate by
saying those least it's monthly in my
place
and weekly services or we have the other
problem that if we refuse it there's a
possibility that these children their
parents are the most vulnerable children
as well won't be able to access their
schools but when it comes down to the
main reason for this the reason for this
is SAP and Borough Council have failed
to negotiate a contract that is
acceptable because they're changing
their procurement well that is not a
reason for us to make exceptions so once
I have every sympathy with the company
and every single thing with we people
that may be affected by a decision
I certainly will support the refusal
because we should not be doing making a
decision on safety on commercial lines
so I certainly would support councilor
hoy motion thank you hey Mason council
mr. Goode in please
I would I would wholeheartedly endorse
all those points that have been made we
cannot possibly change the rules even
when we've got such vulnerable children
going into vehicles we just can't do
that so I would be against and and
support what council highs put forward
council ft please if you counsel the
Western I'm a slightly different opinion
here I'm an opinion that people would go
through mo T's these vehicles are twelve
years old they've gone through IMO T's
and I'm sure they've been completely we
feared we've brakes hand brakes
everything else that has they need to
have a safe to be a safe vehicle for
road worthiness I feel that they don't
attend when Tim Wheatley check on these
vehicles they're doing to MO T's a year
I think they're going above and beyond
what is what is legally we quite for
having a vehicle on the road I do
understand that this children going to
be in there buffing his impact on these
two
June ganger school where children have
been able to go just call for months now
so I honest I would actually support
this thank you
Thank You councillor ducats my mrs.
Macpherson please
Thank You chairman um yes I do know
access anyone quite well and the
services they provide I would like to
ask under 6.2 under the risk
implications it does say however in
order to minimize this risk access
anyone has confirmed they carry out
preventative maintenance checks on these
vehicles at 10:00 weekly intervals um is
there any way on that this will be
checked or followed up if the officer
could advise please thank you Stephen
can you yes if requested by yourselves
we can actually insist that they fought
a copy of those ten weekly checks to
ourselves and we can always you then
have a look at them and all see them we
can flag up if there's any sort concerns
so yes we can ask for those checks to be
presented to us can I come back um
should should just go for what I would
like that idea does it a recommendation
please
Thank You mr. McPherson we do have a
motion at table at the moment okay
counts as anybody else wants to speak on
this okay but we had a motion on the
table to refuse by council council Lucas
Gill I think was indicating oh sorry
I've seen that one count so Lucas you
did you once have a a word I think he's
frozen
that's Bakersfield your mic still on off
off counselor
sorry my assistant he's playing up on
fortunately but I have to agree
everything that the councillor FD has
said I do feel that with all these extra
pets that the vehicle which will be
quite safe to use so I cannot support
the emotion Thank You councillor
Lucas Gill okay so we have an emotional
table to be few seconded by a council
real concern members will take a vote
Sonia do you want to do the Linda place
councillor FG recorded vote for against
or abstain for the motion to refuse no
recorded vote trying to work outside
against the motion to refuse thank you
counselor mrs. Gooding no recorded votes
and I am for the motion to refuse
counselor hoy against recorded vote and
for the motion councillor Lucas kill the
motion Thank You councillor mrs.
Macpherson again mr. recorded vote and
against the current motion clance Lewis
is Mason no recorded vote and forth
motion to refusal councillor Marik could
you repeat that place nice - recorded
vote
again Thank You councillor mrs. Shaw
no record you voted for the motion thank
you and /or hence recorded vote for the
motion counselor mrs. western Nanakuli
Viton abstain please plants were
Wilkinson no recorded vote and fall
emotion six for the motion for against
the motion one abstention so that the
studies carried for refusal I think that
concludes the meeting if I'm correct I
think everybody saw attending the
meeting closed the meeting now at 11:25